here's a story when John and I is an
actual story that John and I have
discussions on outside of a camera
pointed at us Ridley Scott says Neil
Blomkamp's alien 5 is dead
to quote there was never a screenplay I
just wanted to make more alien films so
I was an [ __ ] and said why don't I
just do this prequel that no one would
really care about as much about but they
would probably really prefer to see
Ripley and Hicks back and you you know
because alien 3 upset people so much so
why give them the fan film they actually
wanted I just want to take over the
franchise because I'm old and I got a
dish out more of these and I got five of
em that I have a really distinct slant
about that keeps changing every time I
talk about it and I need to figure out
what that plan is going to be and I need
to do that out loud in the cinema in
front of you I know you guys are excited
about this other thing but listen I got
a I got to rub my dick on this for
hi guys it's Greg here and it's John
here we're gonna review alien government
today cumin onion said before we do that
how Eisenberg wanted to give a shout-out
to him he was the first person ever to
become a member of the patron community
he's in a longtime supporter of this
channel and I just wanted to say I love
you House Heisenberg he found our
patreon before we even made an
announcement before we set up any
rewards he just saw it and was like hey
I'm gonna make a pledge so in just I
love you I love you Jewish Walter White
anyway let's talk about alien covenant
um yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna just hop
straight into this and say I really
enjoyed this movie brother I was pretty
damn good actually I'm pretty sure I
liked it a lot more than you did I think
yeah and I wasn't to say I didn't like
it I just I wasn't enthused yet yeah
leave me it's a solid movie I mean I was
just happy it was a lot better than
Prometheus I thought it was just a solid
entry into the Alien franchise I mean
the cast is pretty damn good even though
there's an actor in there who yet you
might expect to see but you won't
yeah I was especially keen to the viral
videos you can see the viral videos
you'll be more confused when you watch
the movie for at least one repay yeah
the ensemble in this film is really good
the actors are awesome Billy Crudup as
the the captain of the ship in the movie
on a spoiler you've seen the viral
vision Billy Crudup I thought he was
great in this movie very layered
performance what I liked about this
movie is you don't get a whole ton of
backstory on these characters but you
feel the actors provided a lot of
backstory and their homework for their
performances yeah this takes a different
approach from Prometheus like this is a
nice blend of alien and Prometheus in
terms of tone but one thing they did was
they scaled it down into a very
immediate Authority see yeah you don't
get a ton of history on backstory I
think Billy cross was good actor already
and he surprised me in this movie he's
tripped he's terrific in a film
Katherine water Sun water slurs well
understood yes she's really good Danny
McBride it's excellent in the movie as
well yeah and highlight performance
as with Prometheus is Michael Fassbender
and but in this one you get to Michael
Fassbender's yeah yeah and well yeah
yeah you get David and Walter and it's
cool because they're both Androids but
they're two very different Android very
different demeanors very different times
of voice and you get scenes weather or
both are interacting with each other and
it is like there's two different actors
in the same scene he does an amazing job
in handling that knowing the responses
and reactions you would give his
performance in this film was was
definitely great they evolved both of
Walter and David and they really evolved
David to definitely and loved the way he
was handled I do too and if you're going
into this movie looking for something
interesting or looking for it to add a
facet to the alien Canon that is the
most interesting thing that this movie
is is the the whole play between Walter
and David and all that stuff that comes
out between them is the most fascinating
thing yeah if he does to me I'm going to
give you a spoiler that is not a spoiler
this one was a great blend of Prometheus
2 plus alien prequel in this movie you
do get answers some you do you get an
important in you get you get it yeah you
get an important answer you get you get
the you get you get you get to actually
understand some of like where this
creature comes you get the answer from
me see it's a little bit bit it doesn't
make room with us a little bit better
but you're it's not going to find out
who the engineers are oh yeah I don't
care about I'm sure that right now
you're still not going to know a damn
thing about the engineer again about the
engineers but there are other questions
you had other things that Prometheus was
setting up that you felt they didn't in
on or give us answers to you do get more
of that because this film is solid it's
a very specific theme about creation and
by the time the movie ends where the
journey goes I thought was very it was a
solidly done story I would say the solid
sci-fi thriller for sure with some very
like terror induce yelman all the alien
action in this movie is to the tune of
terror it's all angry and fast and and
ribbing in and
this is gory movie yet delay weather or
a lien attack there's a lot of practice
as those you see in the trailer you got
a neo morph and you got a xenomorph and
when the neo morph comes in there was
some girl the first like legit full-on
sequence with the neo morph that was
super intense very gripping and it
earned an applause from the fever
yeah theater applauded after that
sequence was done because you were like
oh man out we got something that we
wanted la I was really well done violent
brutal like the end but beyond that it's
staged so damn well yeah is there really
in terms of this technical construction
especially this movie is really well
done there are times when I wish the
action wasn't so close up and buried and
editing but most of the time it still
comes through as vicious and then scary
yeah and it's cool to have a lean be
scary yeah there's a Prometheus didn't
really have much horror for me yeah I
mean I thought it's one of the right
level of ambitions in terms of deeper
themed explorations and I felt they
actually concluded on a reasonably good
note as opposed to how Prometheus does
it yeah so the performances are great
the directing is solid the writing is
good I will say that even when it was
all said and done and I walked out thing
and that was really good I've walked out
feeling that way I also walked out
saying this is the third best alien
movie which might not say a lot for
anyone but it filled a third this alien
movie in my opinion it leaves you with
less things to go why about you know I
still think that like Ridley Scott
doesn't really have something completely
original to offer here I feel like he
just had the cool free coaches it's more
it's more in the script of where the
originality and the new stuff is offered
it's not so much in what where these
Scott is doing like yes he's created a
suspenseful thrill ride that is a solid
entry into the Alien franchise with good
production design I feel like look
Prometheus he was trying to achieve
something very different
yeah unique he's shot really far and it
didn't really pan out well for in terms
of most people's opinion
here he scaled it back made it a much
more contained story more simplified
more solid at the end of the day that's
all this really
is is a really good entry as an alien
film it suspenseful xenomorph is cool
neo morph is cool you get some answers
in some history that actually makes
sense designs cool the way predators is
cool I just like predators more because
predators is more like fun that's what
kept me from being as enthused as you is
like I never got fully pulled into this
because I was like yeah this is just
proving to me that really Scott can
still do what it does and there's not
really a special reason that we're back
here it's not really like a special
unique tone or style to it it looks
really cool it is pretty cool but
there's not much more than cool but I
wouldn't say it's a special so that's
the missing piece of it because alien
special aliens is special for me yes you
wanted it to be specially here I think
you were just like I just kind of make
it good to know return it I've got to
prove to everybody that I know what I'm
doing yeah there are things about
Parisiens that are like what were you
thinking yeah on the other hand I do
respect a solid straightforward injury
yeah yeah I would say like go watch it
if you're a fan of the alien movies
yeah go watch this film because it's to
me definitely the third best one if
you're disappointed with Prometheus when
you had anticipation for it I would say
go watch this because I think it's way
better than Prometheus yeah so overall I
think the film was a success in terms of
worried that I think people including
ourselves were feeling because I was
just relieved too for the movie to end
be like I thought that was really good
as much later than permit because that
but I think my excitement was really
playing a factor was I was really
invested and a lot of it was really
awesome and suspenseful I do like some
of the reveals actually there was
somebody there are some reveals and some
answers that we got in the way some of
those scenes were done I mean you've
seen the trailers but man there's very
specific things that I remember there's
a very specific scene that would have
been a million times cooler if the
trailer is show you spoil it that this
thing happens everyone right before it
happened I looked at you're gonna set
that damn tree
and thanks for all that suspense because
there's a moment in the trailer that
plays out cool in the trailer but it
happened so late into the film that it
would have been a million times more
effective and impactful
I thought about trailer getting give it
away I thought about that during the
trailer - I was like it's the only way
I'm not going to be upset that I saw
this is better early and not important
yeah it's seasoned actor I am aware of
so I doubt that will happen and whose
room you know and one thing I thought
that was cool about it too was I mean I
know when we've seen the first couple
alien film those were practical effects
here I mean they're all CGI I will say
that if worked like it looks really good
it would like degree the gritty - I
don't know filter they haven't going
over the whole screen the entire time
aided in terms of like xenomorph effects
and neo more effective spine bursting
stuff you saw was excellent it was a
great transition from Prometheus into
alien yeah I think it is a good fit it's
definitely a step in the right direction
I'll give them it doesn't give me hope
that Ridley Scott's grand plan about
making five of these movies to connect
that hey Liam I don't believe in his
plan in light of this movie but I do
appreciate the value of a fun alien
movie yeah you know the other thing I do
want to point out is I think the
ensemble in this movie really does shine
because I like one thing the alien
movies I feel like usually get right
like in a Texas Chainsaw Massacre movie
it's hard to get it completely wrong
when you have like creepy towns folk
because that stuff always works and I
feel like one of the things about alien
movies that always work is the report of
the crew yeah because like when the
crews hang out they really feel like
people who are on a ship for a long time
or in these situations like everyone in
Alien movies for whatever reason is
really natural and I think that speaks
to really Scott's casting process yeah
he knows how to cast and I think his
cast here is really good even down to
characters like Demian Bichir who aren't
you know even the actors I didn't know
as well everybody brought something and
there's some moments like there's that
famous moment from the trailer the one
girls inside the containment bay and the
other girls on the outside they're
freaking out and all what to do about
this alien creature and like that's a
really muddy yeah and I like that that's
a money scene like that was a good
writing decision is like this is a tough
situation where you can look at the
years ago I wouldn't have done that but
I get how you did one thing I'll say
about the xenomorph thing I finally
figured out how to say how I felt about
it the xenomorph was cool the xenomorph
are something really funny about how
like extra slimy use other enemies drew
like a woman every time you see an alien
they're just dripping from their
blankets like their mouth is a faucet of
drool I mean one thing that I felt was
kind of a missing ingredient for me in
terms of xenomorph territory was
prometheus is supposed to be the
reintroduction and in this film starts
off as another reintroduction when the
xenomorph comes on is treated like we've
been around for the xenomorph this
entire time like it's kind of treated in
a way like oh yeah their energy the
franchise and you know it's about those
you know more thing you know so you're
like the xenomorph just kind of comes in
and that it's like there but it's not
like treated anything bigger than that
just becomes the xenomorph this is the
first and Ear work is a thing to fear
now it's good anymore the Dean of
emotions become a bothersome thing for
me in terms of this new phase of alien
because they started off with the whole
like no Xenomorphs and then yeah when
the xenomorph shows up it does treat it
as though you've kind of always known
even though at this point in the plot
and we haven't because the ends a new
pretty new crasher because it should
have been a solid reintroduction to the
xenomorph here it was treated like okay
well they just repeat a moment that
we've seen before
yeah in order to do it it's fine it's
fine I even like go of the practical
effects thing I was like when I saw the
CG I was like yeah it was a pretty big
about the chest first thing yeah and
that's a hard you know I understand we
had an alien Mazen Horan eyes and just
wearing like those suits was causing
people to passed out I understand it's
hard to play an alien so I let that go
and for the scenes that I use azita more
for two it makes sense yeah so my only
thing is I wonder what the purpose is to
bring Ana xenomorph back after making
such a big deal about not doing that
what's the purpose of this beyond just
like oh cool I know what this is and
also love watching and kill people
nothing in this movie ever transcends
that to me yeah because the whole point
of Prometheus and this was finally to go
what the hell is the origin tale of the
xenomorph
so when the xenomorph shows up it's not
I don't feel like it's treated with that
extra specialty of this
you know more origins you know yeah and
I and I don't feel like this one in to
be xenomorph origins from the bigoted
like that I feel like there's a
metaphorical chest burster this
franchise is now suffering from it is
nizina more yeah all Prometheus is
setting up why did the engineers create
the human soul like that's one of the
big questions why like where's the way
we don't want for me to creators of
water why they create all this stuff and
they don't answer any of that and then
here they they definitely don't answer
any of that well I do give you answers
into xenomorph origins I just wonder
what they want out of it but because the
thing is the Prometheus goes off with
all this big questioning and this whole
like we got to find where we came on
bigger expansive universe than just
scary monster in space and this one
doesn't do that and the original alien
to me didn't read as a movie that it's
like all this is about a huge mythology
with purpose and it's all linked back
into where we came from and I don't
think it's a bad place to go but but
alien covenant it only gives you one big
piece of canon information I just wonder
where this franchise is headed I wonder
where they could have gone to if they
stuck with any of that number west from
idiots world and more and just stuck
with what Ridley Scott was initially
saying about how we're aliens you know
we're probably won't show up for like
three or four movies you know like if he
stuck with that because it seemed like
he gave us a thing that students like
asked him to give because this is what
the audience wanted which was you know
more bored all the other big stuff that
Prometheus was setting up kind of
pushing the set again I don't weird the
thing about about billa's all arrived
yeah that's where I'm struggling with
with these two films especially because
as much as there is to complain about in
prometheus Prometheus swung really wide
and tried to at least ask a bunch of big
question and it seemed like its mind was
focused on some big philosophical stuff
yeah that's where we want to take this
now and that's cool if you have some
good answers and this doesn't give me a
hint that they have any answers they
really want to think that hard about it
which is fine it's a fun movie but
nothing in this movie ever pulled me in
past oh cool this is just
good execution of what I've seen on
emotions yes there were three of us in
the car ride home as we were talking
more about this and you know that we
finally got like oh there's you know
more origins explanation it actually
made some things as we thought about it
more a little bit more confusing when
you take the franchise into a whole yeah
and when you are like wait a minute that
way I think you said x-men and I was
like yeah is what I started to breach
that continent yeah I'm like wait a
minute this doesn't make sense because
of this this is innate sense and like
maybe they'll try to tie in those holes
in the like the next alien installments
but I thought this was a solidly well
done entertaining film and I said I was
like if this movie is that I'm gonna
walk out saying thumbs up but it doesn't
live up to the bigger things that
Prometheus was trying to go for scene I
still feel like Ridley Scott is not
making the film he truly wanted to make
he but again deliver us an entertaining
solid thrill run at this point after
alien 3 for Prometheus a BPA VP requiems
it's a good step in the right direction
I think yeah I'll definitely give you
that you go back into some of the old
trailer reactions you'll see like my
whole thing going into this was like
it's got to be better than just a cool
alien movie but than anybody who's not
but but again I had a good time I liked
what they did yeah I can't really fault
this movie on a bunch of stuff because
especially after all this I was like
thank goodness that you just made a yeah
a straightforward contained immediate
movie a couple things surprised a couple
small things surprise me if you know
that you will be satisfied just seeing a
pretty good alien movie then you'll have
a great time yeah you want anything more
than that if you want this beloved
property that this respected filmmaker
created you know then you will be
wanting something else yeah I mean and
by the time it's over I don't think
you're going to be like all right I'm
cool with not having an alien but I
think it was Neill Blomkamp doing it I'm
after sort of like I wish I saw that
snow that is so moist it was like that
one because what these are also doing in
me now is making me wonder
is this going to be the format of this
new franchises everyone okay cool we
crash-landed on this new planet and
gotta bunnyhop we didn't expect you can
read or xenomorph yeah new characters
new planet same set boss bender shows up
yeah yeah in terms if I'm just removing
all of the other contexts of solid
thrill ride it's there's some good
terror gets worth watching in the
theaters alone for the first full on you
know neo more sequence sure because I
thought that was all super intense and
that applause I was like I was I was
feeling that applause out like that is
over well or like how could you applaud
at something just being so good at being
suspenseful and like scary and on on
edge and I heart racing on it it's not
like oh man we have a guy from an alien
movie in years
yeah you'd feel a collective sense of
crowd relief because yeah it was just
like oh thank goodness
yeah like well done good that was there
I would say my consensus would be it's a
solid entry into the Alien franchise and
third best alien movie yeah yeah yeah
I'll give you that is it solid
alright subscribe to the real rejects so
you can catch reasons today Jerry
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house and the real
rejects click that notification bells
check out our patreon more on their
cameras about to die oh it's gonna die
it's gonna die